wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you do
you have michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn some of the
habits of billionaires
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one learn with robin sharma when i coach
the superstars i notice they all have a
trade in common they have massive levels
of what i call curiosity iq they
understand that the person who learns
the most produces at best okay so
greatness belongs to the learners and
fortune favors the curious read an
autobiography
or you read a book on productivity or
you look at your game charts on
your targets or you listen to a podcast
or you watch a video course but you give
yourself that learning because as you
know more you can do better
in many ways the people who create
empires the people who
change history are people who are
incredible students you know you never
want to lose a white belt mentality
because nothing fails like success i see
it with so many companies i work with
members of the fortune 100 i see it with
professional athletes you know they have
a championship season and they start
resting on their laurels and they you
know stop learning they stop mentoring
they stop pushing themselves to the
limit but one thing the a players and
virtuosos all have in common they
understand that last year's championship
season it is this year's starting point
habit number two list out your projects
with brendan burchard here's how i want
you to think through your day from now
on first and foremost i want you to list
you know the one two
three
maybe four or five
projects that you have in your life
right now and i want you to list just
what are
three simple things you could do or
three three things you need to do to
advance those projects
now these do not have to be necessarily
your daily to do's these are the things
that have to be on your radar of things
you must accomplish to advance the major
projects of your life forward let me
give you an example if one of my
projects is
uh write and publish new book
okay if that's it
one of the things i have to do is you
know as part of moving that forward is
write book
two
find agent
three create promotion plan like those
are big picture things i need to do i
might not necessarily do them just today
we'll get to that but those are things i
need to have on my radar to remember
that these are the big projects i'm
working on and these are the major
components of moving those forward by
starting strategically each day and
thinking about the major projects we're
working on and how we're moving forward
in life again assuming you've studied
our previous videos where we talked
about having a purpose right and
thinking about what's my mission today
then when we get to the project level
it's it's just keeping on the burners
it's helping us understand what it you
know what are the things i've got to
make sure i'm working on and paying
attention to
the second thing i want you to focus on
is the people in your life and of two
categories i want you to brainstorm
every single morning i print this out
and i work through this
next this people category i want you to
think through two things
i want to
think of categories of people as one
the waiting on category
and two
the reach out to category
and here's what i mean by that
i want you to sit and think about every
morning
who am i waiting on a decision for
or information from
for me to move forward in any of my
projects or ultimately what my
priorities would be in other words if
you just sat and you brainstormed every
morning who am i waiting on
what information do i need from whom
who owes me some data who owes me
something that i've been waiting for and
until i get these things i cannot move
forward i want you just brains from that
without opening the computer right we're
not in your computer yet say it again we
are not in your computer yet okay i
already think about what is
who are you waiting from and i just want
you right now i might be like oh from
tom i'm waiting on this proposal um from
so and so i'm waiting on this email from
this person i'm waiting on the decision
about the event coming up and i'll just
brainstorm that often i can find very
easily 10 to 20 people i'm waiting for
something from
then again do not open the inbox then i
want to think about well who do i need
to reach out to today to advance my
projects why need to reach out to an
agent well i need to reach out to
someone who knows about book promotions
well i need to reach out for some and so
who knows about this event i need to
reach out from this person who i need to
learn from this person from that i want
you to think about who do you need to
reach out today that would advance the
projects of your life
and brainstorm all those people okay
i'll talk again how you're going to work
through these
next is your priorities i want you to
list
five to ten things
that you must do
today that's why it's a priority these
are must be done
know it do it accomplish it today not
five days from now again these projects
some of these things you might be able
to knock off today but some of them
might be big picture things you don't
get to priorities these are my skit twos
habit number three work out with
priyanka chopra morning which was a time
i try there are days at least thrice a
week i try and like get to get in like
quick workout you know you have those
abs now so i'll say okay today is my
eight minute workout and i'll do some
eight minute like something or abs or
whatever and then i'll forget the next
day so i'm never consistent with it but
the one thing that i try and do mostly
is skip
i love skipping i learned it really
really well in school and then i learned
it even better during mericom so i try
and get my cardio in by skipping it's
easy to carry you have your skipping
rope in your bag it's easy to do also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video i've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number four do neurobics
with marissa peer what is neurobics well
neurobics means doing something new i
tell everyone the mind is brutal it has
a use it
or lose it and when you use your mind
constantly
you find new neurons all the time which
is why professors of 85 have almost the
same brain capacity of someone of 35 but
we have this excuse oh i'm too old now
it's normal to forget things it's my age
when actually little tiny kids forget
things go to a school and you'll see
every day on the peg someone's forgotten
their coat their lunch their swimming
stuff
but we start to think well yeah i'm
tired i'm forgetful
it's my age it's not your age it's
because you are not
using neurobics if you look at a child
they color they get up they can do
something else they come back they're
always doing something new
and new means use it or
lose it you have to train
your brain to stay young and active and
sharp and there are many people of 95
with super sharp minds and other people
of 60
who are letting their mind kind of
wither away and
if you put all your work into having a
great fit
young looking body
but you're forgetful there's no point in
that if i could choose how to age i
would choose to mentally age really
really well because then i could say
well i'm 95 and i'm alert and i'm wide
awake i wasn't having a great body when
i can't remember anything or focus or
concentrate
but you can have it all you can have a
fit body
and a fit mind if you use neurobics and
here's the great thing about neurobics
you don't have to go to the gym
no membership is required no hour of
doing press-ups and lifting heavy
weights and doing lunges is required and
it doesn't hurt you go oh my stomach
aches now and it's really hard work
doing all these chest raises
takes five minutes it's free it's easy
so let me show you
what neurobics is it means new
but it also means the wrong hand most
people are right-handed if you're
left-handed you're going to have to
reverse this if you're
right-handed like me what you need to do
is clean your teeth with the other hand
it feels kind of weird but that doesn't
matter and even better when you clean
your teeth with the other hand
balance on one leg for a minute
for 30 seconds but do something with the
other hand when you reach for your phone
use the other hand notice how much you
use this predominant hand for most of us
it's our right hand we use our right
hand to reach for things to comb our
hair to pick up our phone
train yourself to use the other hand
every day reach for something
with the other hand and know that every
time you do that you are making yourself
younger and here's something amazing
wherever you start from in your house
you will always
if you're right-handed start up the
stairs using your right leg wherever you
start from it's quite fun to try you
will always go up the stairs first on
this right leg make yourself lead from
the left get to the stairs and put your
left foot on the stair first
because you are firing new neurons the
mind loves newness it needs newness
so do some new things clean your teeth
with the wrong hand and balance on one
leg just for a minute when you clean
your teeth
reach
for your phone
your paper your cup your spoon with the
wrong hand use the wrong hand
start going up the stairs using the
wrong leg the unfamiliar leg and finally
and this is really easy
if you do a crossword puzzle every day
because these things are really good for
your brain crossword puzzles suduko
mind games anything new if you're
learning something new like a new
language
doing anything that's different is great
for your mind habit number five is to
have a routine with tom bilyeu now that
the blinds are opening we can actually
see something so i keep my clothes right
there next to my bed
keep headphones right next to my bed
that way i am ready to rock and roll as
soon as i get out first thing i do is
put my headphones on
uh i start listening to a book or a
youtube video then i would come in i
would brush my teeth
again i did all of this earlier because
i didn't want to wake up lisa
but just by way of recreation that's it
so i would come in brush my teeth then i
snatch up the dogs
feed them the key part of any morning
routine is the order in which you do
things so
for me depending on what's going on in
my life i may prioritize the gym or i
may prioritize meditation but one of
those two things is almost always going
to come first it's going to be pretty
rare that i don't do that now as the
time that we're recording this we're
going into the summer so right now i'm
really prioritizing the gym also coming
off of the quarantine where i was maybe
a little bit more relaxed hyper focused
on the business
the gym was something that came a little
bit later in the day the problem is
depending on what your priorities are
and mine is definitely marriage first
then business then physique
that if something crazy is going on in
the business and you know i'm trying to
get things done there then whatever i
haven't done first thing in the morning
it's possible that it just doesn't
happen so um right now because i'm
really focused on the gym even though my
ultimate priority list hasn't changed
the reason i'm recording this now is
because as you guys know i wake up so
early that there was nobody to film me
doing this stuff but the way that i
think about the gym right now it's the
first thing i do so i wake up i put my
gym clothes on i immediately beeline
to the kitchen if i'm completely honest
i feed the dogs and then i
uh
drink a bit of water and then i head
straight to the gym
i do a pretty simple workout routine i
do a push pull legs and abs so
push meaning i'm doing chest and
actually i do it in a different order i
do pull
then i do push then i do legs and abs
then i repeat the cycle habit number six
be grateful with dean graziosi my nine
minute routine as soon as i open my eyes
is i try to think of and we all know
this i'm gonna say something that you've
never heard before try to be grateful
but here's what i've done i've lowered
the bar of gratitude
everybody in this room has accomplished
so much that sometimes we set the bar so
high with gratitude we don't realize it
like we're look we're searching for
gratitude like how did every something
spectacular happen how did the mo the
stars part of the clouds part and i saw
like no like wake up and realize 150 000
people die every day
today 150 000 tomorrow yesterday
you woke up
sometimes i wake up and go wow these
shits feel amazing
god this is a comfy pillow like just
find something and all yours is just
tricking your brain to be grateful in
the moment not a big long gratitude
process and i'd love i love to meditate
i've been meditating more than i ever
had i'm just talking about your first
thoughts and if you if you have troubles
with that then grab a book that you love
you know there's a couple habits books
out that are really awesome right now
this is like
high performance habits millionaire
success habits there's some great habits
books i'm just saying no but grab a book
that you love or the bible whatever
fills your soul and just read three
sentences just so your mind is opening
up the moment you open up you're filling
it with gratitude you're filling it with
appreciation you're feeling it filling
it with personal growth right so the way
i look at it is i protect myself
offensively by leaving my phone on
airplane mode don't check it yet
i do a couple minutes of either
low-level gratitude or i'll literally i
love the untethered soul i love a lot
you know i love a lot of books but the
untethered soul for me i can open up any
page read two sentences and get
something from it right so i'll either
read that and then soon as i do that i
just immediately think of some intention
for the day now guys this is literally
all in minutes i'll think what do i want
to accomplish today what would make me
feel good today literally this morning i
woke up i said today i want to live the
experience with this crowd i don't want
to go up and try to remember what to say
i just want to be present i want to
serve and habit number seven the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is meditate with david lynch what is the
most important thing you practice daily
in order to achieve your goals your
daily goals and
get you to success transcendental
meditation is obviously the most
important thing to do day in and day out
transcending is the key to a better and
better life
and this idea is catching on more and
more in the world
the receptivity to transcendental
meditation is growing by leaps and
bounds
thanks to so many in this room and so
many else others around the world
it's really happening it's built for the
human being
and transcending our nervous system is
built to transcend an experience that
unbounded eternal
infinite immortal immutable ocean of
pure consciousness within
it's money in the bank
meditate regularly and then the second
thing i do is drink coffee
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think are going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the good deed of the day
this is something new i believe that
you're able to serve and it feels so
good to do something nice for somebody
else so good deed of the day put down in
the comments one thing that you need
help with that you're working on you'd
love some support or guidance on and
then two go
comment on somebody else's comment and
give them some love give them some
support give them some encouragement
maybe give them some connections try to
help them solve that problem even if
it's saying i believe in you that one
little bit of encouragement can be the
difference between somebody quitting and
continuing on so the good deed of the
day in the comments below write down one
thing that you need help on that you're
struggling with that you're working on
and then part two is go give love to
somebody else in the comments too and
let them know that you believe in them
as well when somebody asks me what's the
most important part of my morning
routine it's remembering the intention
how do i want today to go not just
having a list of to do's but actually
writing down how you want to feel and
that message to yourself to give you the
extra push that you need to move it
forward come up with your intentions
whether you want to do my method and the
night before write down your calendar
and how you want to feel or if it's just
the first thing in the morning you're
you're looking at your calendar that's
what i used to do before writing it down
i just pull up my phone
load my calendar and just see what was
on my list for today because i'd often
forget what am i doing today i don't
know i just woke up i'm tired i look at
my calendar and then with each one i
would just mentally go through instead
of writing it how do i want to show up
for this person if i'm making youtube
videos how do i want to show up
on camera how do i want to show up for
my audience how do i want to show up for
you i would just mentally think about
that as i go through the day and i
basically wake up go to the bathroom
pull up my phone and start going through
my calendar
that's it and how i want to feel the
intention going through each individual
item on my calendar
what i love about this
is i find that i'm a little more
courageous
at night compared to in the morning i
just had a day hopefully it was a good
day hopefully i served i helped
it's often after i answer some questions
on instagram so i'm in the service heart
and mindset
and i think about how do i want to show
up tomorrow if you find that you have
more energy at night or more clarity or
more boldness at night then then do that
think about how do you want to show up
tomorrow what are your tasks write them
down and with each one just write down
what the intention is how do you want to
show up as a human for each one so not
just a list of to do's but how you want
to feel going into each one
look these are even as an example every
day at 2 30 i spend time with nina
okay
every day 2 30 take a break from
whatever i'm doing spend time with
nathan we usually go outside for the
walk with the dogs
if it's raining we'll stay inside and do
something together just a quick break in
the middle of the day to spend time
together and that's in my calendar and
on my calendar it says
2 30
half an hour break with nina
but i wrote down what's my intention
right so not just time with nina i wrote
down
have fun and make her feel loved
i wrote something else down yesterday
but that's my that's my intention for
today have fun and make her feel loved
so last night i wrote that down i'm
looking at nina she's lying in bed she's
you know about to fall asleep and i want
to think how do i want to show up for
her tomorrow for our break
have fun
and make her feel loved
so i look at that again this morning
and i look at it again right now
and then here's what's gonna happen at 2
30.
2 30 i'm going to be done filming my
videos i'm going to look at my calendar
look at my sheet here and say 2 30 time
with nina have fun make her feel loved
just that reminder
will make me show up differently
if your goal is to have fun if your goal
is to make somebody feel loved you're
going to show up slightly differently
i'm going to show up with more love with
more energy maybe pull in some kind of
joke maybe picking her up and turning
her in a circle something i'm going to
show up slightly different because i
reminded myself that it's not just
a break
the intention is to have fun
and make her feel loved
and so if you do that for all of the
items on your calendar
for every meeting that you've got for
every quiet time that you've got for
every creative moment that you've got
how do you want to show up if you can
write it down i love the night before
and then under each one how do you want
to show up that prime
when you look at it just before you go
into the task will help you show up as
you'd like as your most bold courageous
proud self what are the three things we
should say when we wake up in the
morning or think
well first i would say
what is the greatest ideal of myself
that i can be today
and i would not get up until i felt like
that person
the second thing i would say is can i
begin to keep my energy up the entire
day and if i do it properly then i will
be open to opportunities and
possibilities that weren't there before
the last thing i would say is could i
sustain
brain and heart coherence to the point
where that intelligence within me that's
giving me life begins to find a door to
open out so i can begin to see evidence
in my world move because when you move
in the morning and you sweat you'll
release bdnf brain derived neurotrophic
factor
which will optimize your cognition it
will make you think more effectively as
you go through your day
did you know bdnf actually helps you
promote neurogenesis which is actually
the creation of new brain cells bdnf
through sweaty exercise will also help
you repair brain cells that have been
damaged through stress powerful because
the quality of your brain sets up the
quality of your performance
sweaty exercise in that first 20 minute
pocket of move of the 20 20 20 formula
will also release dopamine which is the
inspirational neurotransmitter which
gives you fire in the belly as you go
through your day universe
university of toronto did some research
and found that the effects of a morning
exercise actually lasts 19 hours after
your workout
cortisol the fear hormone is high in the
morning exercise will reduce it
exercise in the morning will release
serotonin which is the pleasure neuro
chemical which makes you feel happy
through the day now it's 5 20 you're
feeling fundamentally different we make
our bed we start our day with excellence
how you do anything is how you do
everything now keep in mind one of the
big questions we got was
where do you get all the time right to
do all this and i'll show you i said
i'll go at the end how long each thing
takes but i'll give you an idea when i'm
making an event how long it takes to
make your bed very very little but i do
this with excellence and then you take
excellence throughout your day
remembering my dreams takes just two
minutes to go through
the next thing here making the bed only
takes one or two minutes uh drinking
water that doesn't take any extra time
if anything is just you're always you're
already doing it three minutes exercise
it adds things absolutely because the
big thing is where do i get time because
my goal is for not this not to take time
is to help you to make time and focus
and energy and productivity and more
um exercise three minutes brushing my
teeth should take the same amount of
time that's interesting cold showers if
anything it's less time tea smoothies on
occasion sometimes i do intermittent
fast and you might have heard episodes
of that i've done
with past experts journaling
here's what i do i take three minutes to
journal and what i'm like journaling in
the morning i'm writing down three
things i want to achieve personally and
three things professionally now the
biggest way to save um
time on this is it's not just what
you're doing it's also what you're not
doing notice the thing i
said i i didn't say i did which is touch
my phone and i know this is
controversial i understand some of us
have to check our phones because our
life depends on it our career depends on
it again
take these guiding principles and apply
it for you when you find yourself under
stress
and anxiety things go wrong you get
disappointments things don't work out as
you hoped you must feel
a moment of anxiety a moment of stress
how do you deal with that what happens
um
i can
go out of the stress i can at at any
moment like there are times when i i
feel the stress of the circumstances
and then i can
at will
go out of that stress
and just
see things
in a different way and it makes me feel
um almost like a ninja you know when the
in the ninja everything seems to come in
slow motion
you know and in the sense you could step
back and it's coming at me
at slow motion and i can deal with it in
in a way that makes me feel more
centered and in control but like tennis
players they say at the height of their
game
the ball seems to go much slower the
whole game slows yeah and it's really
that equanimity
that produces that kind of a reaction as
distinct from
when you have the anxiety
there's not the clarity there's it's all
coming too fast i always try to hire
people that are smarter than me and that
complement my skills skill sets like i'm
a i'm a ready fire aim guy and i always
try to partner with people that are very
anal and perfectionist to kind of
balance me out or have a skill set that
i don't have um but once i'm going i
mean i would go to events and like this
and listen and learn and go to
conferences and when i get the
opportunity i'll ask questions
but i'm not i can't ever say ever where
i've said
i'm gonna call this guy and just see
what he thinks for this woman and just
ask that's just not my style i mean
because at some point i'm gonna have to
be responsible for whatever that
knowledge is
and and and also i have the benefit of
being in the technology business and
it's uh it's a benefit because there's
always something new coming and i've
always had the attitude that whatever it
is so if it's virtual reality if it's
the oculus rift it's new to everybody
except the people who invented it and so
i'm i'm at first base like everybody
else and then it's just a question of
effort of learning it as well as
everybody else so other than going to
the originator of the idea concept
product service whatever
i'm tied with everybody else and and
having the opportunity to learn it so
i'll just put in the time to learn it so
from a tech perspective and that that's
always served me well because once you
understand these different products you
understand how they fit together and it
also helps you make decisions and
understand what will work and what won't
work here's your new definition of
passion
passion is simply
energy
that's all that it is okay
passion
is what you feel
when you are energized and excited
about what you're doing okay i want you
to think about that for a minute i want
you to think about a moment in time
when you felt incredibly passionate
about something okay and why don't you
in the comments tell me where are you
watching from and tell me about a moment
in time when you felt incredibly
passionate about what you were doing
about where you were
about the people that you are with
describe that moment for me because when
you start to
really investigate
passion as energy
this is what you're going to discover
those moments when you're super
passionate like i'm sure my kids would
write down when they're doing community
theater with all their friends
i would write down whenever i'm doing
any kind of creative project with my
team
i'm incredibly energized whenever i'm
doing group
exercise stuff climbing a mountain
doing a 5k race doing some sort of
walkathon i'm incredibly energized by
that whenever i'm um doing some sort of
creative project incredibly energized by
that whenever i'm working with our video
team incredibly energized by that
whenever i am
coaching someone or giving advice i am
incredibly energized by that and so what
i want you to understand is that if you
look back on your life you have had
moments where you have felt
passion
i'm being very deliberate now i'm
talking this morning on coffee talk
because passion is a huge topic for so
many of you and you've been so focused
on trying to figure out what job is
gonna make me uh passionate what job is
my passion what is my purpose on the
earth i'm gonna tell you what your
purpose on earth is right now your
purpose on earth is to figure out how to
align your life so that you feel more
energized and excited by it that's it
and it begins with you
following the energy and following your
natural enthusiasm
you're not going to think your way to
passion you can't think your way to
finding something that you feel in your
heart it doesn't work that way you got
to feel your way into it it's inside of
you do you understand there's no passion
out there somewhere the passion is in
here and so what you have to do first is
you've got to stop thinking that you're
going to find it somewhere and you've
got to realize that passion is about
unlocking something that's already in
you and so here's the thing
so for those of you that have been
watching coffee talk for a while or
you've read the five second rule book or
maybe used the five second journal or
maybe you took mindset reset with us
this january you've probably heard me
talk about the fact that inside of you
there is power you have an inner compass
and that inner compass is always guiding
you and learning how to read that inner
compass is essential if you want to
unlock the passion that's already
naturally
inside you
passion again isn't a person place or
thing that you're gonna find it is a
state of being that you unlock inside of
yourself and it is there and you can tap
into it right now
so there is an inner compass inside of
you that i call an energy gauge
it's an energy gauge that reads the
energy in you and around you and that
energy gauge goes from moments when you
feel depleted dead and empty to moments
where on the other side of the gauge you
feel energized alive expanded and so the
truth is
your natural state believe it or not
is to be
on the energized expanded side of the
internal compass that's in you
and so you are never really lost i'm
telling you this i know you may feel
lost i know you may feel defeated i know
you may feel depleted i know you may
feel stuck these are all temporary
states and one of the fastest ways for
you to start to change how you feel
about where you are in your life is to
tune inward and to start to read the
energy because if you feel stuck your
natural energy is depleted if you feel
despair your natural energy is depleted
and the fastest way to start to shift
that is to shift the energy inside you
and to start to align your life towards
things that energize you if you think
about
visualization is simulation
now here is the difference whoa that's
good okay go ahead so visualization is
simulation so
when we close our eyes or even if our
eyes are open and we start to use our
einstein brain the imagination
we now have just activated one of the
biggest centers of our brain the
occipital lobe that's connected to the
motor cortex it's connected to the
motivational circuit the nucleus comes
that releases that dopamine that makes
you feel good that makes you want to
take action so if you visualize
yourself achieving the goal if you
visualize yourself behaving in ways that
match the new belief if you even
visualize the words or you take the
words on a sheet of paper
and you read them run your right finger
across it run your left finger across it
close your eyes see it and feel it your
brain is creating a mental movie with
the words and as it creates a mental
movie with the words that's happening in
your subconscious mind
and when you give the subconscious these
instructions a couple things happen
because of the way the brain hierarchy
works number one it's survival but then
number two is safety and the number
three is energy conservation now when
you do something 20 30 40 50 times it
takes about 66 days to
365 days of repetition to override an
old habitual circuit not 10 days not 21
days 66 to 365. so if you visualize
yourself achieving the goal feeling the
success that you want to feel
seeing the belief on the screen of your
mind you are actually creating a neural
network through the science of
neuroplasticity
and the networks that you reinforce
become the most dominant networks and
since your brain wants to conserve
energy
if you do this on a consistent basis
your brain says okay
you're doing this so often let me just
make this automatic let me set aside the
old beliefs let me replace it with the
new beliefs and now you've deliberately
and consciously evolved yourself so i go
to bed with the intention of pure
awareness
and settling into
infinite formless
identity
and i cultivate that awareness in sleep
i've been doing that for decades now
and so i have a
witnessing awareness experience even in
deep sleep or dreams
and there's a recognition that i'm not
the body mind
then when i wake up
you know before i get into the identity
of deepak chokra which takes a little
bit of time
i just have the same
awareness between
waking and sleeping and then between the
sleep state and the waking state is that
little gap of pure awareness
and i enjoy that
and then i start my meditation process
and
it's all while i'm still in bed i
i'll obviously sit up to do that
and then i go have a wash or whatever i
have to do and then i do yoga i do yoga
seven days a week
when i'm traveling i still do my yoga
every day seven days a week in my room
i always get a yoga mat from the hotel
you can design your days you can make
your life about what you want it to be
about so what do you want it to be about
what should you majority of your days be
about for you in terms of creating
contributing and connecting but they
what should they also be about for you
your character who's going to show up on
your ideal day
what would you be like on your ideal day
would you be weak and fearful or would
you be courageous and strong would you
be judgmental and mean and upset full of
hatred and
jealousy and anger and regret about life
and other people or would you be
somebody who's open and excited for
other people and connecting with other
people and positive and enthusiastic
what would you be like on your ideal day
have you ever written that down here's
who i would be on my ideal day here's
how i treat my wife my partner my spouse
my lover the kids here's how i treat
strangers here's how i treat other
people and then the idea is don't wait
until the end of your life
to have that ideal day don't wait until
next year or next week to have that type
of day we can choose to wake up every
single day and live that day in an
idealistic way for ourselves in a way in
which we show up as who we want to be in
a way in which we are doing things that
enliven us and engage us and get us
excited in a way that we're doing things
and being with people and creating
experiences that feel alive and
fulfilling we can have that type of life
i call it the charged life and everybody
can have it it's a matter of discipline
in getting it and here's one simple
trick and tool to make sure you get more
of those ideal days when you start your
day you must own your morning
you must own your morning look if you
thought about your ideal day i bet you
didn't say well i roll out of bed i grab
my iphone and i check my email right
that's not an ideal day you have to own
that morning to make sure that you're
proactive with that data to say you know
what okay what is i want to be about
this day what are the things i want to
achieve and create and experience this
day what kind of character do i want to
cultivate today what do i want to learn
today give today grow today you have to
have some aim and intention to have a
phenomenal day and it's not that you
can't go with the flow and the bumps and
the bruises and the struggles and
hardships of life but when you're
experiencing those you can still
experience them from a place of presence
and peace and enthusiasm
even the ultimate challenges in my life
and i've faced i've lost friends i've
lost my father to leukemia i've been
through my own multiple brain injuries
car accidents atv accidents broken
enough bones in my body it's kind of a
sad story really but every single
hardship i've ever faced including
leaving and starting my own business
even
moving to new cities every major
challenge obstacle in my life i always
chose to meet that as my ideal self i
always say well how would my highest
self interact with the situation i'm
making the bed
even though we're checking out of the
hotel this morning
because every single morning i have the
same simple morning routine kit
i get up on the alarm rings i get moving
i get my exercise clothes on i move my
body i then journal do a brain dump i
make my bed
and even though we're checking out of
the hotel
it's so important
to keep to your routine because the key
to changing your life
is change your daily habits
the way that you start to change the big
things is you change the small things
make tiny teeny teeny promises to
yourself and then keep them so i have a
promise to wake up and get up for myself
for years and years and years i would
get up to make the school bus i would
get up for school i would get up because
my mom was telling me to i would get up
because i had to get to work i would get
up to get my kids to school
today i get out of bed with the alarm
rings for myself
i make the bed
as a gift to myself
now normally when i'm home
the gift is i get to come back to a
nicely made bed and i have a beautiful
place to lay down and dream
it's also a gift because i start my day
by completing something
but it's also a gift
even though i'm checking out of this
hotel this morning because
i am
building the foundation for all change
which is consistency
so here's how you put this into practice
think about what you want your morning
routine to be come up with just one
promise you're going to make to yourself
is it going to be to get up on the alarm
rings is it going to be to make your bed
let's start with making your bed
tomorrow morning you're going to wake up
and you're going to make a promise that
you're going to make your bed for
yourself
do it every morning and you are building
the habit of consistency
and that habit of consistency is the
backbone to all change every weekday i
wake up at 6 00 am i haven't set an
alarm for a long time but i know that my
body will naturally wake me up based on
the routine that i've created
i usually sleep for about eight hours a
night and i'm very grateful to have that
much time and i prioritize sleeping at
about 10 p.m every single day
when i'm up the first thing my mind
wants to do is say something like i feel
so tired i've got so much to do today
and i as soon as i wake up in that
moment rewire and reprogram it to say i
am happy i am healthy and i am healing
that simple internal affirmation and
statement rewires how i feel about what
i have that day i'm grateful for the
opportunities in the work i have i'm
healing with the challenges i have and
my body is healthy because i'm able to
get out of bed i don't look at my phone
in the morning trust me i don't always
follow this i've broken that rule many
many times i'm not perfect i failed at
it countless times but i keep trying to
rise back to this rule why because i
feel amazing the amount of clarity in my
mind the stillness that i experience
when my phone isn't the first thing that
i see
is
inconceivable and i highly recommend
that you try it out just for seven days
don't look at your phone first thing in
the morning and see how different you
feel for the rest of the day i promise
you you're going to feel more energetic
more productive and more creative than
you've ever been before now i've been
practicing something for a long time now
called mindful brushing
i brush each tooth for around four
seconds before i move the toothbrush
this mindful process allows me to start
the day
at my own time in my own pace
so often before i used to rush brushing
my teeth not only would i be damaging my
gums and damaging my teeth by the way
dentists will tell you about that i
actually was starting my day off in a
panic with stress
slowing down the first activity of the
day
allows you to start and move at your own
pace in your own time what i want to
talk to you about today is a note which
i call daily
so if you create a new note
in your notepad or something that you
check on a daily basis this is the most
important thing
name it daily
and then write the word do
colon
and then go down a few lines and write
the word don't
colon
the one thing i would ask you to do
walking out of this
is to every single day just for a week
wake up to this note
check it throughout the day
and then also before you fall asleep
check to make sure that you did and you
didn't do everything so what you put in
each one of these is you have a list of
everything that you want to do every
single day and you have a list of things
that you don't want to do and the
easiest way to add to the don'ts is to
notice something that you never want to
do it again you never want to do again
and you just add that to it
very very simple i'm just going to share
some of mine these might be a little bit
personal and embarrassing but here we
are
number one on my do list is to stay
present
i think it's so easy to get trapped in
the past
it's so easy to think about the future
the most important thing is i stay
present and just reading this
brings me back to the present brings me
back
to this moment
number two for me is be vulnerable
show people my mistakes
show people my fears
because they can relate
because they're going through similar
things
number three drink only lemon water
and red wine
great red wine is a great modifier for
it
this goes with one of my don't which is
don't drink hard liquor or beer on
weekdays
number three is uh six sets of 20 squats
and push-ups throughout the day i just
have to do them every day
uh six sets of 30-second planks
run for three miles
meditate on this list
stand up straight
which whenever i say i always see
posture moving in the audience
say hello to everyone i just bought a
heavy bag so i'm training with a heavy
bag so i want to spend 10 minutes with a
heavy bag every day
i want to do a video journal every
single day and i want to get seven hours
of sleep
on my don't list and again this is one
of the hardest things and a lot of these
are personal so i'm not going to read
all of them
but my don't list is don't avoid eye
contact
don't be late
don't set expectations for someone and
not meet them
don't eat sugar
i'm on the paleo diet so don't eat wheat
lentils or dairy
and then of course don't drink hard
liquor or beer on the weekdays
so this list well it sounds very very
simple
has been fundamental in establishing
patterns for myself
and it's something that i do check every
single morning i check throughout the
day and i check right before i go to bed
and i make sure that i check everything
off
and go through it i've given it
to our companies
i've given it to a number of students
that i've talked to as we've gone to
schools and recruiting and people have
come back to me and said that this is
something that works for me it's
something that's easy to do and
something easy to remember
one of the most fundamental things about
it that i've learned that i've taken
away from it is how it gives you focus
how it gives you something that allows
you to really ignore
everything else that's going on all the
other noise to allow you to focus on
what's most important so this do and
don't list for people and individuals in
the company has translated to a do and
don't list for our company
for square we have a do and don't list
we have these are the things that we're
going to do these are the core things
these are our bold bets and these are
the things we're saying no too for right
now
has been fundamental in allowing us to
move fast to continue to innovate and to
really push the boundaries and continue
and question
and and reset everything that we think
about the organization i mean the
balance of work and play is critical
and i think a lot of people don't get
that balance right you know i'm 63 years
old now so uh critical to
find time for yourself get out there and
keep fit and and i find the best way of
keeping fit is by playing
[Music]
i try to
encourage our chief executives worldwide
to make sure that there's as much
flexibility in in the workplace as
possible
we've set up something called the b team
which is examining the way companies
treat their staff and trying to make
suggestions to make the dignity of work
better than it's been in the past
if you're too close to a situation you
know like in an office you get bogged
down with the manuta uh if you can step
away from the situation
uh you can think about the bigger
picture and that's what i'm able to do
on there
[Music]
the most extraordinary people come to
necca the elders was conceived here on
mecca with archbishop tutu with
president carter with kofi annan
the carbon wall room was conceived here
an organization that tries to work with
industry to try to extract carbon out of
the earth's atmosphere you know sitting
in muhammad looking up at the stars at
night things like virgin galactic
so great place to think and the great
place to conceive ideas
well we had a fantastic day it was a
sunday so it wasn't all work so um a
great way of capping off the day watch
the super bowl with a cup of tea and
the chair
the most important part of a morning
routine is how you feel about yourself
it's the number one thing that people do
not pay attention to that matters the
most is how do you feel about yourself
when you're done your morning routine
nobody wakes up perfect nobody wakes up
full of energy yes ready to go
i can't believe today is another day
what a day to be alive i'm so grateful i
like nobody nobody mel robbins evan
carmichael tony robbins nobody
the difference between where most people
are at and the people who have success
is that they demand
that they show up and they create that
through the routines and the habits
which is your morning routine it's the
easiest way to just get started so you
go from being tired and having stuff in
your eyes and lines on your face and
rolling out of bed to then feeling
inspired motivated ready to take on the
day
how do you do that well
you have to find the thing that actually
makes you feel powerful inspired
motivated confident and ready to go and
most people
just go through the motions and i'm
talking to the achievers now most of
america most of the world doesn't have a
morning routine at all they fall into
their day they wake up like an accident
and they start
falling to what other people want them
to do for the day like most people wake
up and just immediately go to their
phones see the crisis and they're
rushing off to go work on somebody
else's dream they wake up drop the job
that they hate to work on building
somebody else's dream that's most people
you guys watching this you're probably
more on the achievers side you probably
have some kind of morning routine you're
probably doing more than your friends
and the people around you
the challenge with achievers and the
morning routine is
most of the time you're going through
the motions to just check the box and
feel like i got it done as opposed to
actually getting the feeling the most
important part of a morning routine is
the feeling
so i had on my tour i had a woman
in albuquerque new mexico
talk about morning routines and she
asked me what mine was and i told her
what mine was but mine doesn't matter
what matters is what you're doing and so
i asked her what what do you do in your
morning routine well the first thing i
do every day is i pray
okay great so you pray and
let me let me ask you an honest question
i need you to be honest right now it's
important for me for you for everybody
here
how many times when you're doing the
prayer when you've done the same prayer
so many times
when you when you're going through the
prayers how many times are you just
saying the words because you know the
words you've memorized them you see them
a million times
how many times you've just seen the
words
and how many times you actually feel the
deep connection how many times you
actually feel
the power flowing through you
and i forget what the number was it says
40 something like when she actually
feels the power like that's the problem
that's the problem with achievers
you are going through the motions of
your morning routine without without
ever having the feeling
so that you finish your morning routine
whether it's 10 minutes an hour four
hours however long your morning routine
needs to be
if you don't feel confident alive bold
powerful at the end of your morning
routine then your morning routine isn't
working
i don't care that you checked the box of
having done your prayers or watched that
video the number of people who watch a
video but then you're doing it while
you're making your bed or brushing your
teeth or eating breakfast or whatever
you're not ever really intentional about
watching the video that's great you can
check the box of saying you watch the
video but you didn't get the feeling so
it doesn't matter if you don't feel more
powerful confident ready to take on the
day at the end of the morning routine
then your morning routine is broken and
needs to be fixed and it's either adding
something new in
that actually makes you feel that way or
just doing the thing that you already
know works but with more intention
so that's what the woman need to do is
go back and fix some more routine just
with more intention
we often compare ourselves to other
people and their morning routines the
morning routine envy and say well
they're doing it so i should be doing it
like that i should be working out like
the rock four hours a day well that's
probably not what you want to be doing
the key is figuring out what makes you
happy what is the life that you want to
live understand that your routines
really are set up for you
to have the habits to follow through on
success that you're looking for right
success has happened success is what you
do on a daily basis and your morning
routine sets you up for that so how do
we actually then create a morning
routine that works
right let me let me get
practical move from just inspiring to
some tips that you can actually go off
and accomplish
step number one the most important thing
what makes you feel the belief in
yourself
of all the things that you do
that you've tried that you've done what
makes you feel the most belief in
yourself
maybe it's watching a video like this is
why i design these videos to try to be a
part of your morning routine i'm honored
for anybody who is is using these videos
uh
as that so thank you but whether it's
these videos whether it's reading the
book whether it's meditation prayer
working out getting in nature
petting your cats like what is the thing
that makes you feel
belief in yourself
that you're capable of more that today
can be a great day because you're not
don't have the expectations of you
waking up feeling great you won't you're
going to wake up like yes
but what is the thing that you do the
most that has led to you feeling that
love of belief
and you can string together a couple
like when i do this and this and this
and this great
this becomes the seed of your morning
routine
so make that list set number two
is there a sequence to them
what what's the one thing that when you
just start doing that thing it
kick-starts everything else
so that's why making the bed is is
something for a lot of people it's not
that making the bed actually makes you
feel motivated it's that you're the kind
of person who makes the bed and then
it's what happens next is that when you
make the bed you're more likely to then
do the next thing
you're picking something simple as the
first step not because of
it actually doing anything to make you
feel great is that it
makes you do the next step and the next
step and the next step so making your
bread brushing your teeth flossing your
teeth like whatever the thing is
what's the easiest part of the routine
because working out for example working
out on your list that's hard
you might have lots of energy and
excitement now but tomorrow you're going
to wake up and not want to work out even
though you know logically you know that
working out will get you feeling ex exp
not expired inspired
hopefully not expired inspired motivated
for the day you feel great after workout
you don't want to do the work in the
morning
so don't make workout your first thing
something easier that you can fall into
so making the bed
brushing your teeth or there's something
else drinking a glass of water like
you're the kind of person who drinks a
glass of water in the morning so then
you follow through on the next thing and
the next and the next thing so you start
stacking them
right so step number one is you make a
list of the things that make you feel
the belief the courage the motivation
the fire and you you put that into
routine but step number two is now we're
going to order them
and figure out what is the easiest best
place for me to get started on these
things
so that i can still follow through on
everything else that when i do that one
thing everything else cascades in order
and then step number three is just make
it realistic
make it realistic you can actually do it
one of the biggest problems that people
have with morning routines
is you
create this perfect morning routine that
takes you four hours to do
and it's unrealistic for you to actually
follow through on you'll do it for two
days and then realize wow this is
this is just not happening i'm not i'm
not doing it and what that translates
often is then therefore you suck
because you can't follow the routine
therefore you suck and then the whole
day gets thrown away and the next day
and the next day the next week and next
month nothing ends up happening
certainly being focused on something
that you're confident will have high
value to someone else
and just being really rigorous in making
that assessment
because people are
tend to
a natural human tendency is wishful
thinking
so a challenge for entrepreneurs is to
say well what's the difference between
really believing in your ideals and
sticking sticking to them
versus
pursuing some unrealistic dream that
doesn't actually have merit and it's
it's that is a that is a really
difficult thing to to tell you can you
tell the difference between those two
things yeah so you need to be sort of
very rigorous in your self
self analysis
um i think certainly extremely tenacious
uh and
um
and then just work like hell i mean you
just have to put in
you know 80 hour 80 to 100 hour
weeks every week
and then a lot of work that all those
things improve the odds of success okay
um
i mean if if other people are putting in
40 hour work weeks and you're putting in
100 hour work weeks then even if
you're doing the same thing you know
that in in one year you will achieve
what they achieve you will achieve
in
four months what it takes them a year to
achieve if you practice any new skill
for 66 days in a row through the power
of neuroplasticity which is the brain's
ability to adapt
then you are going to reach a point
called automaticity i want you to think
about that term automaticity in other
words after 66 days of practicing the 20
20 20 formula
and joining the 5 am club and running
the morning routine you're going to get
to a point where it's automatic you're
going to get to a point where it's
actually easier to get up at 5 00 a.m
than to stay in bed
i also want to offer you a brain tattoo
from the book to consider as you wire in
this learning protocol of billionaires
and highly creative people professional
athletes and industry titans and it's
this all change is hard at first and
it's messy in the middle and it's
beautiful at the end i'm going to repeat
that again for you because it's so
important all change is hard at first if
a new skill or a new routine or a new
habit was easy
then it wouldn't be valuable change so
anything that's valuable
is hard at first you know society says
live an easy life i suggest to you that
whether it's a great morning routine
whether it's building a great business
whether it's releasing your master work
to the world maybe it's a great
relationship maybe it's a great interior
life
it takes real effort it takes the long
game it takes focus it takes hard work
it takes bravery
but the rewards are so much more
glorious than living an easy life okay
so and also remember the things you once
found difficult
you now find easy little kids for
example find walking early on difficult
or learning a new nursery
rhyme or learning how to read or
learning how to build relationships at
first there's not a lot of facility and
fluency with those skills because every
skill is difficult at first until you
practice it and then train until you get
to a place where you master it and so
your morning routine is going to be
challenging at first but with daily
training
and practicing the 20 20 20 formula i
promise you you're going to get to a
point of mastery
and then the payoffs are extraordinary
your creativity will soar your
productivity will maximize you will
actually attract more prosperity into
your life because the marketplace
rewards true creativity and productivity
you're going to feel so much more
happier in your day you're going to find
that sense of peacefulness so it's
almost like you go through a life with a
greater level of grace and ease you know
the way you start your day determines
the way your day is going to unfold
[Music]
if you want another video of the success
habits of entrepreneurs check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there so i live only five or six
minutes from the spanx headquarters but
i actually many times leave my house an
hour before i need to be at work and go
on a fake commute